names Max Lombardi and I've been an
agent for ten goddamn years you want to
know what it's like let me tell you
about it
the Lombardi tails
welcome to your orientation I made you
max Lombardi I'm your instructor on
account that my leg is broken and
someone in personnel hates me now you're
here because the possibility exists that
you're not jackasses and Mike could be
useful in the containment of anomalous
IRAs we're not gonna try to kill you so
let's start with the basic mission we
are out to find out which in and bring
it back and then contain it you're more
scholarly colleagues are the ones who
studied from my bulletproof glass and
[ __ ] about how hard their job is
they're receiving a similar briefing in
room 67 they got doughnuts and coffee in
there just in case you was hoping there
might be a modicum of justice in this
cold uncaring [ __ ] of a universe anyway
so me use it gonna be retrieval like me
whilst others are gonna be containment
you might even switch it around
sometimes retrieval is generally
preceded by investigation by Intel Intel
who also have coffee and donuts
in case you're wondering how far the
budget stretches well go forth find
leads gather facts and then tell you
sweet [ __ ] off on receipt of this dearth
of information you will go out to exotic
locales where you will be forbidden from
stopping and having a drink or
conversing with the locals what I'm
trying to kill you you will go to where
Intel tells you that whatever the [ __ ]
is an agent much higher on the food
chain that you will go and talk to
people for the purpose of figuring out
what's going on do not envy this agent
[ __ ] goes wrong he's in the worst place
possible anyway once it gives the
go-ahead the rest of the team comes in
takes out the skip as quiet as possible
skip by the way is what we call
anomalous entities I'm sure I don't need
to tell you where it comes from
now sometimes skips don't want to come
along as quiet as we would like I mean
sure maybe it's a nice inanimate object
that don't hurt no one or some guy who
don't even want
go around free he's hurting someone most
of the time it's something easy but
sometimes it's something that really
don't want to come along
quiet like and it has the means to
enforce its wishes so you apply stronger
cores ideally in Tobal have figured out
what the skip can take and you proceed
directly to enough firepower to knock it
loopy
Adelia we would have doughnuts and
coffee since we usually go in knowing
jack [ __ ] you'll start off with your
bare hands and work up from there
now at a certain point it looks like
you're gonna have to choose between
catching the skip and coming home on
your own two feet
who here is willing to die rather than
give up the mission one two three four
okay you five fail
counter to what something bats will tell
you the ladder is actually the preferred
option capture and skips is the name of
the game but find an agents who actually
do the [ __ ] job it's hard and you can
always catch more skips later on your
best option is to run the [ __ ] away that
way they can always send someone else in
to grab the [ __ ]
if you can't and it comes down to a life
a limb situation that's when you pull
out your gun and you shoot the [ __ ] if
that don't work you shoot it again
because 99 times out of 100 shooting
will work if you do enough of it this
don't mean you got to leave to shoot
everything that moves cuz agent Lombardi
told you so
you don't when you got it we aim to
bring these things in whole and intact
but if there ain't gonna happen the
foundation will set off a study on
what's left so them's the basics of
retrieval the rest of you are gonna be
involved in containment now
containment is in some ways easier you
know where the skip is and hopefully you
got some idea what the damn thing does
and how to stop it
however there are some complications
first off
the skit might be watching you too
depends on how smart it is that means
it's got a better idea of what we can do
it gets out it's gonna know what the
uniforms mean who's likely to be armed
it's also gonna be pissed
ideally it's more pissed at the guys in
white coats sticking needles into it but
might remember it was you and your
buddies who rolled up and brought it in
there also unless you're a single skip
site if it gets loose it might let the
other [ __ ] out too
and suddenly you're dealing with five or
six skips instead of just one now they
might just start fighting amongst
themselves but you're gonna have to go
into the middle of it all break them up
and they ain't just gonna play alone
also remember how I said most of the
time retrieval is going after something
harmless yeah you don't get that luxury
sure some of the skips you got in the
safe but some of them will rip off you
and scoop out your brains and you're
around them every [ __ ] day this is
especially true if you're at one of
those single skip sites I mentioned
because they don't put them kind of
resources to work to watch the [ __ ]
vending machine so that's life as an
agent for you questions you put the
glasses in the turtleneck how weird
well I once saw a guy have his bones
turned into jelly
grape jelly huh yeah they did this they
all came back grape they're weird enough
guy with a buzz cut shoot who decides
what we go after generally it'll be the
site director in charge of retrieval
ultimately it goes to the o-5 council
but they're really more in the general
strategy than day-to-day operations okay
you want a messed up person I don't know
where this [ __ ] comes from its Intel's
job to figure that [ __ ] out
please refer back to my previous
statements unintel
redshirt third row health benefits
they're great if he come back alive
we got the best doctors on the planet if
it's possible to get you back on your
feet again they'll do it yes you in the
back with a duck the upside to the job
well for one thing we could pay pretty
good for another if you don't do the job
the world will probably end that ain't a
joke seriously someone has to do this
job you want to live to see tomorrow
good choice okay Toby much a question
how do you get in one of the groups with
the coffee and donuts you go [ __ ]
yourself
that's how okay yeah skinny twerp with a
goatee clef clef he's a research to
slash agent slash I don't know what the
[ __ ] seriously most of the stories you
hear about him a [ __ ] the rest are
all so [ __ ] but maybe based on
something that kind of happened once if
you squint them in any case you ain't
clefts so don't get any ideas when you
being around a while then you can start
thinking about emulating them except
you'll be too smart to okay the Dame by
the door the monkey oh that's dr. bright
he's harmless that being said you got a
Taser
he has genitalia you do the math so that
concludes my brief since you've been so
good I arranged to get punching cookies
and ain't as good as coffee and
doughnuts but hey are they full of
laxatives